this video is brought to you by
liquid IV more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation it is
time for Reacher season 2 episode 8 John 110
it up what's going on John I am am excited for
the fin oh that's really well done I'm sure you
thought of that on the car ride over ladies and
gentlemen be sure to leave a like on this video
thank you to all have been joining us thank you
to prepper for helping us edit down each one of
the highlights for this specific series and thank
you to all been joining us at our patreon page is
where you get the full length Reaction watch along
where you sync up with your own copy of Reacher
available for super sexy rejects of course and
over there we cover several things exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included I'm
ready to see what happens here let's see what goes
on sounds like some liquid Terminator Tunes
actually the lighting here kind of looks like
Terminator yeah it's all blue it's Sleek uhuh he's
a good looking [Music] boy hands behind your back
Reacher he's like it looks better that way what's
wrong with me surveillance photos don't do you
justice you're going to make a hell of a hole when
you hit the ground no no the hole in is season
3 Metal
Gear get him ready ready he's going to
perform for them you get beat up yeah
clemon no you weren't in charge no you're
a sh man damn hands behind his back and all
woo oh boy come on bud wow do something cool
jump over your bound hands or something oo ow
where is she the force of those kicks there's
only one body down at the Corner's office and
it ain't nearing now where is she put the gun
down we both know you can't shoot me till you
find her yeah she's your last loose end right
I can't shoot no ow but he has a family now
I don't want to leave anything for ballistics
dig that slug out of it we got him right where
we want him boss ouch dude how many times were
you up against Brad Pitt in an audition oh no
oh no oh boy God you don't mess with the 110
ah man special investigator is going to get
you let's go sneaking music Neely kneeling
hey it's like the shot of the Jack Reacher
movie oh my God the Precision I would
love to play Halo with you yeah I would
love to respawn frequently with you perimeter
guards neutralized what's your ETA 3 minutes
out who I didn't catch it it's going to be
surprise maybe it's uh maybe it's Ros his
hand is thumbnail let some time go by and then
quietly retire definitely oh yeah definitely a
thumbnail then your boy Swan started sniffing
around brought his Pals in on it and my wellth
thought out plan like a Time Square ouch it looks
like he did the deal and took the money and ran
and I still end up with my toes in the sand and
a bronze ass on my lap oh thank God he explained
it oh but now that plan is gone to [__] too
cuz I got one of youing [__] running around
out there where is she jeez this is most we've
seen reach for messed up Jack bleeder you seem
upset I offered to cut swan in
where is he yeah buddy six feet
deep here you want to see him oh my God
they've reanimated him they brainwashed
him they made him as a Deadpool
machine from or yeah he can't sing
anymore oh see I didn't need all of it to frame
him this his fingerprint to get into the computer
sign off on some documents and his Iris to scan
when he logged in and out of certain parts of the
building that's cruel in a pristine house it
looked like he took the money and ran did you
just carry it around in that jar even leaving
his poor dog behind Reacher hates that oh now
I really want Robert Patrick to die did you teach
him that is this your fault yes that's what he's
been grappling with little bit this reunion is
over I got a meeting with a man that's going to
give me $65 million load those two on a chopper
and then come back for this [__] why can't
they load that [__] on right now yeah well he's
too heavy for one Chopper to carry so they got to
get a few so swan has been helping them yeah he is
guilty from beyond the grave but maybe he's still
alive and they only just took that one finger and
that one eyeball you came through the boy sweet
paratroopers oh boy get to the chopper
leave anything behind go flush this go
flush this awesome I may have some of
my guys go by and find ne's father pick him
up that i' to flush her out of the woodwork
what do you think I just really really hate
Loose Ends yeah dislocate yourself or that
yes yes the faceter the faceter White
Rabbit but those kids back go run them
the hell out of here we don't want any
Witnesses when we leave go murder those
kids when she's 10 ft tall here you go chasing
[Music]
rits I thought I told you kids to
stay the hell away from here yeah
strong middle finger I'm telling you for
the last time get out of here before i k
your ass no it's NE yeah I'm just waiting
for Rosco to return I know post credit as
soon as you have them secure on that copter
go find out why that music is still playing
so that was the plan distract them with
the music okay you're in here with me
yes yeah yeah that's right
go NE boom make America great
again oh Reacher
uncuffed damn Jes
damn there's like one shot left in
there yeah over the shoulder cool
love a cool motion hey hey keep your
head down and stay over there stay
here you just don't mess with the 110 yeah got
to save Swan's eye man this guy's always out
of bullets oh boy the loose end the loose end
arrives hey this look this is Terminator this
is The Terminator cyber D shootout much jeers
airplane or no Hendrick I'm a swan Hendrick is
overrated next's getting away but what about this
showdown with am going to take a few minutes to
warm up first go down right maybe am will blow up
the chopper how much ammo you got not enough to
cover your slow plan on running out of here
going to have to make two I'm free am ammo
so much glass shattering in this
episode how many henches are
there Jack
Runner Jack jumper Jack choer jump
Reacher wow dude you know if Tom
Cruz was Jack reach for still he'd
really be doing that he really did this at full
altitude ladies first it's your
turn sweetheart he could use the
wind to ascend into the helicopter
yes make yourself aerodynamic or
that yes it's raining
guns yes yeah that's what I'm talking about
man damn am OD Donald good call oh man it's
going to come full circle he'll throw him at the
helicopter oh well now what are you going to do
come damn whoa no no it's well stage
sequence wow ow ah God damn it that
this freaking guy Jack really get it hurt
you're an overachiever man [Music] oh this
is like a big action movie finale
Jesus Christ Rich you just don't
know what to hit him with the stretcher
you should be kicking Jack in the balls
yeah no no Jack she can use the
wind to Ascent yes right flip it
up get it you kick him now owie I
can use your Pal's brass knuckles
and smash your skull or you can let
the [__] fall and toss you out
after
yeah dude that was that was sweet yeah that
was sweet wa everyone lives but on you better
hold this thing steady or we're going to find
out the hard way if I can land it yes ma'am
wait wait wait but you won't find out cuz
you'll be dead nice elbow no no no no you
you can still stop the missile from getting in
the hands of a terorist they'll do it either
way throw him where's going to leave myve you
assume that's the information I need langon
but in an investigation assumptions killed
assumptions coill yeah full circle oh dude
that shot that was a really cool line but I hope
you actually know where the hell am's headed you
heard him say that yeah right they're going to
meet one of the new age engineers at his home
so he can teach the buyers how to put the
Little Wing chips into the rockets look I
have the coordinates please just don't kill me
take us there land the chopper right on top of
the house where's a you know he's just fixing
someone's face up giving him some lip fillers
oh yeah we'll forever debate was he right he
starts repairing himself was there a greater
sacrifice there he is the man of the
hour excellent Langston's already here
cuz that' be so fun to shoot this season all that
snow yeah yeah yeah yeah
they finally meet must be some mistake I
don't know any of you people your little
scientist friends being held in the barn with
the pilot you killed our friends prepare to die
I I understand that you're upset but I didn't
kill your friends I didn't even know them but
I know you you don't care how many people die
so long as you get your finder fee arrest me
and get it over with oh know that's not how it
works bet a guy like you I we got a top-notch
lawyer on speed dial oh my God are they going to
all shoot at the same time yes tell us who you're
selling the weapons to oh I'm sorry that would
ruin my reputation and my business not that I
would expect any of you to understand I can see
that you're idealists between the seller of the
gun or the user I prefer to be the seller the
base mindset that a person has to embrace to
actually pull the trigger is no better oh yeah
all right everyone unload I I wanted to hear his
speech oh yeah oh my God my firing squad wowe
you don't mess with the special investigators
we'll forever Wonder was am right this whole
time was it just business M build up to am
was real uh antil climatic what do you mean I
mean that they kept building him up he's dead
now we we did it what do you want to do with
these two oh send them home in a body bag I
didn't kill anyone I only flew the chopper I
was just doing my job what's your excuse I was
just going to show them how to implement the
chips I had no idea what they were all going
to be used for yeah right they can't have been
for something good get out of here both of you
in the snow they'll probably die that's
why he's letting them go the illusion of
Freedom are they going let him
use the helicopter to fly off I
guess so unless they rigged it to
blow like Place Beyond Pines that
[__] oh they're going to blow it
they're going to use the missile
wow Jesus Christ oh and and if it's got
its Little Wing Chip it'll definitely
hit its Target just wait till they're
over the river that's that rich wow
what a boss cold I think we're good
Ney are in the [Music] hole it's so
mean wait for
it fly on Little Wing you got to be [__]
me sorry but Senator Lavoy was clear oh yeah
the senator can't take the risk one of you
might talk I thought you might make a move
as soon as I let him get on the chopper
me too maybe they just really wanted to
see me shoot those [__] down was pretty
cool was sick it was sick figured Lavoy
was the kind of guy that would cover his ass
that's why I didn't just call theoy I also
called Omar Kareem in Homeland hey let's
go Homeland boys are coming back yeah let
me see your hand cutting him pretty close
is government ever efficient no it's not
is it done is it over [Music] almost
there's just one last loose end that
needs tying up I think this is what's
called a win-win you've got the green
Lighty wow one more thing where's the money
what [Music] money you going to
be in the nicest suit next season
you really should take that guy to the hospital
yep you should all go to the hospital it really
needs to go to the hospital he's been shot stabbed
beaten the hosital moved unceremoniously don't
care how cool this looks he should go to the
hospital he's going to bleed out in the booth
oh man there's so many possible thumbnails here y
oh what can I get you coffee black black Reacher
serious pops puffs of pees in that preference
neie doesn't have a scratch on her nope she good
what are we going to do with 65 million of moons
got to use it to make up for some of the pain it
cost what donate it to charity you care less
about money than anybody I've ever met right
sure you should be in charge of it handle it big
guy I think we should give it to that person over
there give it all got 50 cents you have 65 million
3 Ines from you sh boxes don't take bar bonds yeah
what song what song though what song Jack Frank
Sinatra Strangers in the Night I think it'll be
a a snow song uh D Martin Ain't That a Kick In
The Head uh that's a more oh my God possible
thumbnail yeah it's good idea it's a
good idea oh a kind of forgot about
her yeah it's millions of dollars ear
marked for my kids it can't be for my
brother that'swe this is a touching ass ending
take care of the spot card get to move on Wow
J not suspicious at all IRS going to be
breathing down the back of your Thro that
is a whip make sure you get the the logo in there
all right make sure we know who made the car yes
I think at this point I'd be glad
these people are dead yes see it
really worked out for me [__]
but I'm rich now yeah I got an
Audi animal shelter yes oh my God I love this
what a great Montage Mr I'm Connie bumy from
Chicago Home Health I'm part of the team that's
been hired to provide you round the medical care
that's great a I'm going to sleep with this woman
that's the kind of medical care I want what did
you do you'd have felt funny if I just put cash
in your account it won't take it away from your
father I got him a prostitute I tell you you're
a good friend Reacher a not nearly enough nearly
enough hey would the world's scariest Santa
Claus put under my tree this year I didn't
give you a penny commitment I put a shitload
in your kids names Credit Union around the
corner from your house wow you can quit yours
I started a Delaware LLC in your name fully
funded go hang your own shingle too smart to be
working for anyone but yourself yeah wow wellow
thank you thank you Jack llcer what' you get
for yourself I took mine birded I need a new
toothbrush I bought 3,000 toothbrushes they're
all made of solid Platinum when I found out that
you were wandering the Earth with nothing but
what you could carry in your pockets thought
you lost your mind but this show is really cool
there's a part of me that thinks that you're the
only one out of us it's got it all figured out
it ain't perfect but it's a life can't believe
I'm going to say this but I actually miss Swan's
guitar playing right now you could AI generate it
to absent friends it's absent friends spent 70
million making a hologram of swan we can carry
around anywhere with us we should take another
picture yeah we should guess you're not going
to let me just take this one either huh not
a chance boss print one out for him this time
oh there is a touching ending NE don't touch
Rocka away [Music] Beach a one more for the
road he's in Rosco's bed it was
all a dream oh grave I can't leave
Marve good you're awake I thought you'd gone I
did got you a present IB profen it's in a sack
Reacher and they're on the sack Reacher that's
your one it's the one get yourself something
with the money wowe look at that there's something
else you can do name it come home with me I really
want you to meet my parents wow [Music] damn
I'm with you should have seen your face but I
see what we've been doing these past few days
not so much as new business but old business I
have no unfinished business old business they
really needed to be taken care of before this
meeting's adjourned I think this particular
item needs one last going over I second that
motion I saw Donal and I told him that I'd
share with him to the airport so I've only
got him this might take more than a minute
oh give me 90 seconds that's not what odonald
[Laughter] said love birds no attachments
not as comfortable with this Arrangement
as I thought I was years without seeing each
other never speaking getting together only
when we're being shot at need to get better
at staying in touch give him a phone is that
understood Yes Master Sergeant you will will
be a series regular you refer to these special
investigators as your team family soldiers your
familys yeah do it you know we're more than that
right just family come to the barbecue possible
thumbnail where you coming from right here doing
what visiting family hey he said it he said
what it was that she was implying so where
you heading no idea now don't talk to me old
man the patience exercise on this guy [Music]
woo they should have let the the credits play over
just the bus driving endlessly all right reject
Nation so today I want to share something with you
that has been a wonderful addition to my health
and fitness journey that I discovered during
the holidays and that is liquid IV's hydration
multiplier I'm down to my very last packet and I'm
freaking out but it's okay I got more in the man
now a lot of you have been so kind to notice how
I've been working on my physical health thank you
for all the compliments and one thing I learned
is that proper hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre-filming after
post-workout and my wife actually introduced me to
this product which is perfect because we not only
care about quality but a good taste and quality
product whether it's after a sweaty workout or
just after you know a good night out you know what
I'm saying efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better and it
tastes fantastic I can't emphasize that enough and
I'm always on the lookout for too is products that
have zero sugar or zero sugar added because that's
one of my main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products that fit
that description that also tastes good too so
yes thank you so much so liquid IV's hydration
multiplier is in summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers hydration into
your bloodstream faster and more efficient than
water alone cuz sometimes drinking a whole gallon
is not always efficient but in fact it can provide
the same hydration is drinking two to three
bottles of water I'm also big on efficiency
plus it's packed with 11 essential vitamins and we
know vitamins are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten free and dairy free you can customize
the water amount to your taste again perfect for
post night recovery traveling or just having
a big night out you know what I mean no so if
you want to booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid i.com and use
promo code reject at checkout that's liquid iv.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV sure feels like it so stay hydrated stay
healthy and let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024 all righty
ladies and gentlemen uh I for listen this on Apple
or Spotify we just watched Reacher episode8 out
of season 2 the finale for it and I thought that
it was a strong close to this season I thought
it was really strong yeah I remember last season
people feeling a bit up and down about the way
how see I scw I want to talk about last let talk
about this this season I thought uh ended they
they wrapped up everything well it was exciting
it was tense I thought the last few minutes uh as
they were wrapping up with how they dispersed the
money to everyone the $65 million I really don't
know how you evenly disperse all that that's so
much money that's so much it's like okay like
I give this guy five million I give this person
five five 510 I still got like $30 million left
to you know like everyone they cut around to him
like how much did everyone get exactly the kids
yeah there that's millions of dollars but the the
connection between um the our Core group of the
of the 110 special investigators uh the LA the
last episode in this one really let me feel that
Bond and that core unit between them uh and and
it ends on a note where I would like to see them
back I I I i' very much enjoy that and I felt the
uh Melancholy goodbye that he was feeling here
you know like this really is his family whereas
in last season he was a stranger wandered into
town made some connections this really was his
family and he's this the second time he's had
to say goodbye to them and I could feel some
it was kind of clenching in my heart a little
bit I felt I felt the uh the uh bittersweetness
of it all because even though they get to have
like brighter Futures ahead of them due to you
know the financial gains and other prospects that
have occurred from it at the same time yeah it's
you you know Reacher doing his Reacher thing and
reaching on to a new city after explosive action
just kept getting caught up in how he could
like ride a bus and not have like a phone or
headphones or any of that just just like the man
can Master non-stimulation whilst leading some of
the most stimulated experiences I can never fathom
being a part of well it's like that thing they
say it's like you know and I'm sure you you've
experienced this as a person who stopped eating
added sugar is like you know everything around
you all the Natural Foods become more flavorful
when you get used to that so maybe Reacher in
not indulging in various distractions is just
like getting the most juice out of every single
moment and scenario so maybe on that bus you know
he's collecting people's stories he's hearing
the vibrations of the road and he's seeing the
motherland the Heartland I should say in a in a
good I don't know that could be one of it that
could be but it is a it is a funny Trope of like
is he just sitting here staring out the window
the entire time or talking to whatever old person
wants to talk to him there are some funny action
cliches I went down here like I I have a hard
time believing in this world I believe it but
when I step back and think about it Homeland
letting him use the missile on the helicopter
bit a little bit much there U what you did and
there are some storylines that I thought could
have paid off in a more cathartic way the way with
am how they they were really building that up they
they really built it up and it seemed like they
were dividing their time between buildup between
Showdown with Lon or Showdown with am and and am
has demonstrated himself to be the more lethal
ruthless calibrated one so it seemed like oh this
could be a real Foe for him this could be someone
who could not just challenge him physically but
mentally you know they could read a real cat and
mouse game about it especially with the amount
of time they spent separate from Langston and
Reacher just like he had his own show taking place
whenever we cut to him that I really thought we
were building to something with him and I feel
like the show was intentionally doing that so I
did feel like while it's cool when they all like
shoot him uh I did feel a tad bit like oh okay I
guess I guess that's it and because they were like
divided time between him and langon and Langston
as much as he was the guy in charge he never
felt as threatening as am did and because of
that I'm like yeah I wanted linkston to die sure
he did some messed up things but he was kind of a
one-note character he wasn't as interesting of a
character as great of an actor as Robert Patrick
is he's one of our greats he it's the the the
character's very one note very stock yeah he's
a very stock villain with the swear words he's
always like Angry you know he ain't [__] at
the end of the day yeah yeah so yeah you want him
to die but I for me I was at least looking forward
to a showdown with am because with the amount of
buildup they were doing with it so that part a
little let down by and then the stuff with the
senator would have probably felt a little more
rewarding if that wasn't if that was a little
more flushed out too so there there there was
a lot more pieces than last season so some stuff
while always hitting that cool note yeah while
it was always cool and while the performers were
always really good and while you would get like
action and violence in certain moments that
were like sweet and while I felt the emotions
of the wrapup here probably stronger than I did
for season 1 honestly I still feel like H they
kind of missed the ball on a couple of things here
that I feel like could have been stronger and you
know there's other narrative choices that we've
already been over and probably beaten to death by
this point when it comes to like other things
involving like building up the 110 instead of
just saying No Mess with the 110 like really just
getting time with it blah blah blah there's other
things that we've uh really touched on quite a bit
uh but in terms of this finale it was those those
shortcomings that don't make me dislike the finale
I just feel like there was a stronger finale that
probably could have risen up and outside of that
though it is still like very entertaining and I
would really like to see season 3 I'd still like
to see the 110 return M and yeah that's about it
but yeah I mean John do you uh I left a lot for
you there I think I I'm pretty sure pretty sure
that are you going to share your opinion not that
happen in this episode no I would agree I think
that yeah the the totality of this season I'm sure
after season one's major success they probably had
to look around and go okay what do we maintain for
this and what do we tweak a little bit to play to
that much broader of an audience and so I feel
like this is a little bit more down the rabbit
hole of action movie cliches than the first season
not in a again not in a bad way I've enjoyed most
all of it and yeah I do I yeah in terms of
the villain presence I feel like they split
the personality and the physicality in half so
it's like you have Langston who's technically the
like shot Colin action taken guy whereas you know
am is very much like the O this is an interesting
presence and he's got this demeanor and you know
he's always very calm and he's just snaking his
way across the country and uh and yeah ultimately
the impact of both of those is a bit dampened by
a the fact that yeah Langston is just bad guy he's
just bad guy you know and it's a bummer that they
don't capitalize as much like Robert Patrick is
good but he's he's this is the flavors of this
character are things he could do in his sleep and
then with am I appreciate maybe the subversion of
the idea that you're working your way across the
country and you're like oh yeah these plots are
going to collide and it's going to be something
big and even the idea that he's there being like
no I'm just the I'm just the money guy I'm not
you know I don't have the same philosophy like I
thought that was a sort of interesting note that
they started to play before they you know killed
him but uh yeah like for the build of that mystery
and just the cool presence they heaped upon him it
does feel like oh that's like a last minute thing
we got to take care of now by the end rather than
like oh man this major threat is about to get
wrapped up uh so yeah I think the first the only
thing I'll say between this season and the first
season is just that this moves a bit more like an
actual action movie or something like that whereas
that first season moved more like a like an
atmospheric you know regional thing that happened
to have action heavily involved in its execution
um so then you get to moments like in the finale
where they're hanging out of a helicopter and
Reacher holding the stretcher and like I like
that stuff I think that's cool and it's relatively
plausible within this world but it is pushing
further into the realm of big spectacle and things
like that and then you do have to rely on yeah
the idea that Homeland Security will let you use
this like you know corrupted piece of technology
that has like horrific real world implications but
just once cuz you're the good guys you know which
is fine and and and that kind of reminds me of a
moment like the one in I think it was the previous
episode where they like straight up murder that
guy in the hospital and like the the the ways in
which the philosophical aspects of the show are
maybe a little more fast and loose this season
because uh I feel like effects like that last
time around would have been like very fleshed and
very like understood from an emotional and a and
a contextual standpoint whereas here there is a
little bit of Getting By on like well they're well
we trust Jack and they're all just so badass yeah
yeah you know um but but this season still has
things that I'm going to be thinking back on and
remembering I mean everything with Russo I really
liked a lot uh and that left an impact even though
his presence on screen maybe was a bit shortlived
and yeah like all the members of the 110th I like
in retrospect thinking back and going oh man like
we had our suspicions and we were worried that
certain twists would come along and no they they
proved to be the characters that you know the
guy we all trust said they were and and I I
was gratified to reach the end and not have to do
some thing where like a Dixon turns around and is
like ah you couldn't just leave it alone could you
you know or something like that and uh yeah like
the the the places you meet these char especially
somebody like odonnell and the kind of jokes and
the and the you know notes that they pin on each
one to give them their distinct flavor by the end
they all felt like yeah characters bonded with
history and also a new chapter to that history
that we all got to witness so yeah I I still
am like you said really excited for the next
season this one had some adjustments that didn't
like hamper the experience for me but that I did
notice and I am curious to see how they maybe
smooth out moving forward but yeah all in all
this is a pretty straightforward finale but I
definitely was Satisfied by the end I was I felt
like uh you know had a had a nice you know hearty
action meal yeah yeah solid stuff all around and
overall a touching conclusion to a season where
you get the I think they hit their beats perfect
when it came to neie and Reacher at the very end
of how they would have a Sentimental moment in
these two characters specifically you know so I
really feel like they understood it and there's
something about Neely being at the restaurant
completely unscathed like not a mark on her
that just made me love her like uh something
about that specific this girl just she's not
perfect she really tries hard and uh she works her
butt off and then just like look at her at the end
just she's just cool cool as a cucumber right
yeah know I thought that was really fun uh yeah
I really like her a lot and I'm excited I'm sure
she'll be back between all the other members but
ladies and gentlemen what do you think about this
season do you like it more than season one are
you excited for season three what pitfalls do you
think this came to what were your favorite Parts
be curious to know leave it all in the comments
below thank you so much for being here and we will
chat with all you guys soon hopefully see you for
season 3 whenever the hell that comes [Music] out